DC Comics reading Warner Brothers said
by gosh we paid 14 million for this
Marlon Brando narration we're going to
use it till it pays off Barbra
Streisand's hairstylist hey let's make a
good-natured nod to the original
Superman film with the opening music and
credits and then done the franchise with
the rest of the actual film is this a
Superman movie or a Star Trek movie whoa
Saturn gun up you show me pleasures
it took Bryan Singer all of six minutes
to give viewers the mental picture of
Lex Luthor McGonigle a traditional
Scrabble game has two WS and two M's
this board has four WS there are also 14
E's instead of the required 12 what's
that you think this one might be an L or
something else nope it's an E no one who
watches the sky for a living tracks this
asteroid spaceship landing another story
from a theater dude nobody knows the
story of Prometheus not even Ridley
Scott can you see us do you really think
you'd be spilling all the super secrets
if he could tell me everything starting
with crystals Luthor just somehow
already knows that crystals are
important Superman is addicted dogs why
does every superhero we need to have a
wise old woman in their life
I mean Aunt May Martha Kent Alfred
she won't appeal his surprise for
journalism for a single opinion peace I
mean yeah they have a Pulitzer for
editorial writing but it usually goes to
someone who writes a series of articles
and it's usually about something
important like convincing the powers
that be to reverse a decision about
fluoride and municipal water supplies
February 13 2005 was a Sunday remember
she's still in love with you-know-who I
knew it Baltimore they always go for the
rebels it's gonna be legend wait for it
dary it seems that we are experiencing a
slight power outage yeah except for your
microphone
why does Superman take care of the
astronauts first there's way more
innocent lives on the plane which is
also more damaged the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few ma'am
someone needs a sandwich how many after
they're in catastrophic the Pulitzer
prize-winning Lois Lane thinks there are
EPS in catastrophic beyond the
ridiculousness of the glasses being a
perfect disguise for Superman a room
full of reporters who work with Clark
Kent every day decide not to connect
Clark's five-year disappearance with
Superman's exactly equal time of
disappearance why does Superman's super
hearing sound like XM radio when the
signal is bad so when a pilla turn you
can afford to buy the great gatsby house
got it old sport I guess it's a good
thing no one's changing right now or
this would be really creepy Superman
everyone was in love with him but were
you this out-of-control car careens
through the city and doesn't hit a
single crew selection figure the appeals
court calls Superman as a witness and he
wasn't around um that is not how the
appellate court system works uh there is
a potentially fatal buildup of ice
occurring Superman basically flies
straight up with Lois and then when he
takes her back ends to fly for miles and
miles to get there Lois Lane has been
insisting for days that the blackout is
something bigger and more sinister than
a mere blackout and yet she still takes
her kid into the expensive yacht at the
house where the sinister power outage
began she's either a terrible mother or
no yeah she's a terrible mother is a
bunch of wigs really a sight for Lois to
be scared of I mean she doesn't know
it's Lex Luthor's boat for all she knows
it's just a bald guys boat might be
Bruce Willis's boat land yep one of the
greatest super villains in the history
of comic books has been reduced to being
a real estate shark again Lois has a
magic ring that switches fingers in
between camera angles try Superman fun
fact
Superman is actually the 47th most
common computer password of all time
according to what's my past calm below
ninja munkee and but above asshole
panties and bite me surprised Superman
has a kid except not surprised because
you saw this coming 15 minutes into the
movie
wait so this elevator has no ceiling in
it water displacement should have caused
metropolis to be slammed by a tidal wave
exactly how close can Superman get to
Krypton huh because it's all around him
right now in the form of giant land
masses rising out of the ocean so is
this possible see all that kryptonite
around him this is the land Lex Luthor
believes everyone will want to live on
can you even grow anything here it's all
in rock even if people were interested
how would Lex avoid going to jail or
getting executed for this it's like okay
you created land but you have no army
you have a couple nameless henchmen
Cowpens who never talks parker posey and
one of your henchmen was just taken out
by a piano you have like zero leverage
here wait Superman's not capable of
knowing when his powers disappeared see
this is why most Superman movies are
born because the only way to stop him is
with kryptonite and that makes him up
you're looking Lois tugs on Superman's
cape you do not do that this planes
right wing should be broken off or
heavily damaged now plane might crash
but obviously won't really crash cliche
I see Lex in his henchmen also went to
the Prometheus school of running away
from things
Superman somehow lifts the huge
continent full of Kryptonite his only
weakness oh I see kryptonite only
affects him once he's done being exposed
to it wait there was still kryptonite in
Superman from Lex Luthor stabbing was it
on a break for the last 20 minutes okay
after Superman saves the airplane the
newspaper has the date of September 28th
time passes Superman is Superman again
he saves a whole bunch of people lex
luthor breaks into the Museum of Natural
History to get crystals Superman takes
Lois out for a romantic flight saves the
world from Lex's stupid plan and by the
time it's all over it's been one day
also something happens in July Lois Lane
they'll let you in right because
everyone keeps up with and idolizes
their local pilots or winners it's a
movie coma darling I'm sure he can hear
you
will we see you I'm always around except
for that time you went to Krypton for
five years and nobody knew where the
hell you went
no I want to punch you in your time
wasting mouth that is all face I was
offended by your voice if we ever had
the chance to meet in person you
probably could say the same thing about
my voice but I'm never gonna meet you
you guys are just at souls and need to
shut up get laid and move on from your
currently useless lives the person who
made this vid must be getting laid so
mature
thanks cinemasins be a darlin and come
check out our channel i like honest
trailers better boobs
just kidding cinemasins thanks for the
support